you want to do something special you
want to do something special for your
loved one check this out
whether you're shopping for yourself or
someone special Adam and Eve will have
the perfect gifts and with an amazing
deal get just about any item for or
almost any item at 50 off plus free
shipping when you use this podcast
exclusive code Lifeline at checkout
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e that's 50 off an
adventurous new toy a slippery Lube or
almost anything you desire that's for
our podcast listeners okay so you
welcome you get 50 off almost any item
more pleasure in the bedroom is the gift
that keeps on giving treat yourself I've
done it treat your partner I've done it
life is too short to not enjoy yourself
the good thing too is it doesn't matter
what you choose all will be packaged and
sent discreetly for free not only to
save money on gas movies and date night
dinners out but this is the item that
will continue to save your money deliver
tons of fun wink and satisfaction oh
wait so go to adamandeve.com select any
one item use code Lifeline
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e this is an exclusive
offer specific to this podcast yes so be
sure to support our show and use this
code Lifeline to get you not just the 50
off but also the 100 free shipping code
Lifeline go to adamandeve.com right now
I think it matters very little for women
and me too and that's coming from a guy
who's beat out
I don't think you're living out what
doesn't that mean you go like that yeah
yeah no you don't do that what normal
body like that or like that you know no
like that that's crazy dude you're like
the top of a why you're like this
that's just two lines no no it's a
little bit like further out at the top
[Music]
hello
hello hello hello
[Music]
all right it looks like I have an
unrolled
c-o-n-d-o blank M condominium
on your head
um condominium on your head so guys hey
what's up welcome to Lifeline we're
absolutely ripping it
um I will be in let's see New York at
the Beacon Theater coming up and uh and
that's very soon
Providence Rhode Island come on let's
keep it moving dude
Kansas City Missouri Springfield Tulsa
Midland Texas Austin Texas Minneapolis
go to chrysalia.com and get your tickets
Cincinnati Salt Lake uh why do you say
Springfield did not say the state
because it's Springfield in every
[__] State Illinois because I want
more people to go to my website a
different place where I will be no not
the actual reason yeah it's the place in
The Simpsons too right awful
um get your tickets for Crystal on tour
christalia.com you got a question for us
click on the link in the description
below or just go to watch lifeline.com
you want a one-on-one session with your
[__] boy don't swear Prince Daddy-o
your bleeping boy Prince daddy off baby
baby mattelia.com one-on-one session we
go back and forth I help people you help
me help you sketch your session now and
then obviously there is of course all of
the great Lifeline merch at Lifeline
merch.com
baby baby taking too long taking your
sweet time with it doing the baby baby
thing you know what I realized I do and
I don't know why I do it and I've been
trying to figure out why I do this when
I go to sleep at some point while I'm
asleep I go like this
I do I do this with my hands and you
don't know you're doing it I have no
idea that I'm doing it and I wake up
like this come on no cousin it it
totally yeah no you don't all right what
do you mean no I don't I know for fact
you don't I watch you sleep you don't do
you do that yes I do that why would I
why would I make I'm I'm not I mean this
there's just some disbelief it's like
wheel yeah but also you make up
everything all the time no I don't I Can
Fly
wait let me tell you something your hair
looks really healthy did you wash it
recently oh I did I hate washing my hair
dude but it looks better it does it
looks healthier but I hate it why
because I like it but it feels better
when it's dirty and oily and [__]
disgusting disgusting okay it's not
disgusting dude I wash mine today
everyone everyone
agrees with me everyone knows it's good
Trump everyone that acts like it's
better to have clean hair has been
brainwashed by the media the shampoo
companies okay that tell you you need
shampoo oh you need to get rid of your
dandruff oh really dandruff is totally
natural I don't have it anyway but even
if I if I did it would be natural but
the problem is you've been told dandruff
is bad and unhealthy and then you have
to buy shampoo okay and then you're a
sucker okay I only wash my hair every
once in a while worst infomercial and it
feels great it feels terrific what does
he selling life is terrific I'm selling
not buying or that yeah gonna have gonna
be in the black so hard with your
company I'm selling not buying okay I
don't understand really but it's okay
but anyway my point is your hair looks
great my hair I washed it today it looks
great admit it your hair looks good I
think but I said great
no and my [__] looks really good it's
got bodies you said a bad word why are
you telling me not to say bad words for
the first five minutes okay he'll bleep
it out and I did it and it was my
mistake and I owned my mistakes and you
didn't you said no I said shiz okay but
instead of you know so what I'm saying
is it's better for YouTube If we don't
swear the first five minutes so they say
because they're obviously Shadow Banning
us but I'll tell you what dude super
good we're on the super good Channel and
like And subscribe they unsubscribe
people from our Channel yeah it's a cons
it's so crazy people say it's a
conspiracy until you actually realize it
happens
so um I'm basically
a-l-e-x-j-o-n-e-s and I can't say it
because they'll Shadows I don't even
know what you said sitting well you I
know I don't want to because I don't
want to risk it okay well then I can't
respond okay
um so listen
um what's up man how are you doing how's
your week been
um
it's been all right so boring
dog drinks too much water boring
I mean how could you be so boring
starting out the spot it's a sign of ill
health and I'm worried about is it dude
yeah I'm worried about Charlie drinking
too much water is healthy if you love me
send me money to take care of Charlie
but you don't even know what's wrong
with him yet I don't you just don't
hurry to her how do you not know that I
do know that but Charlie's a boy named
so I say him it's also a girl name so
Charlie Baltimore was a rapper also
remember that first down remember the
perfume Charlie yeah yeah was a guy well
it's for women
just with an eye
c-h-a-r-l-i so listen
um
you're doing things so many different
things dude you know what let me tell
you something okay but you're crinkling
you make me mad that's fine but you're
crinkling okay so the madness started
with you I stopped crinkling and you
still make me mad how about that all
right we are very obviously Brothers in
case you don't know that because of the
way we look and even if we don't look
even if you don't see us if you're blind
or if you're just listening to it on
wherever you listen to podcast and
you're not watching it it's very obvious
we're brothers because we sounded like
and even if it's not because we sound
alike if you couldn't tell that you can
tell that we are brothers because of the
way we argue
dude
get off me
get
figure out the look you want dude do you
remember so much printing do you
remember pimp and Pimpin that's right do
you remember when you
told me I could punch you in the face
for 10 bucks and I didn't do it and then
months later you got mad I punched you
we were we were fighting on the bed
we're rolling around fighting each other
in my room and I punched you and I
knocked you off the bed because I'm
strong you didn't knock me off the bed
yes it did I punched you didn't knock
you off the bed you fell off the bed
this is why the story is good okay then
you popped your head up from I was still
on the bed yeah you popped your head up
above the bed so I could see your face
and I was so worried you were gonna okay
kick my ass okay AGN Ashen and I and I
was scared and I froze and you put poked
your head up and you said 10 bucks yep
and I gave it to you and I was very
happy to now have my awesome kid I
remember it dude what I remember is you
were on top of me I was on the bed
you're on top of me we were doing the
thing you punched me in the jaw and I go
10 bucks that's right I knocked you but
it's so far I mean you know off of the
bed with my thunderous jab okay what's
crazy is we remember it differently and
that is absolutely insane isn't that
weird what the memory will do it is but
in this instance it's not weird because
I'm 100 okay then it's weird that my
memory is doing that then it's it's
interesting that you have a bad memory
is what you're what's what you're saying
I'm just saying dude you know there are
things you don't remember correctly and
I think that this might be one of them
but if you're gonna go ahead and take
that hard stance I don't even really
give a [__] because it doesn't matter
you said the f word okay now all right
well we're seven minutes and it should
be okay but Anthony bleep that out okay
listen Jesus man it's like
you are right it is interesting that
people have different memories that's
why you know what is the least bankable
yes evidence in court I wish testimony
right because I didn't actually want you
to answer well you asked it in question
but I wanted to say it okay but you
asked me and then I answered so I didn't
know it was gonna be a Togo next time
again we have a rhetorical question say
rhetorical nope did you know we'll be
bad
okay then it won't be bad it will be
fine what else you got how was your week
it was good you know um we were
recording this two weeks ago so uh I
gotta well no like a week and a half ago
so what I'm saying is I don't know how
the week was honestly okay but I do know
I was in New Orleans and all that [__]
and it was probably great it's going to
be somebody's big day soon
Calvin yeah Calvin's going to be it's
birthday in six days because this is the
12th of February and it's Calvin's
birthday is going to be three years old
dude yay
[Applause]
he's gonna be three happy birthday
holding your tits holding your tits out
for Calvin happy birthday the longest
tits Calvin hey
he's so dumb um so it's gonna be it's
gonna be his birthday and that's gonna
be beautiful and we love that dude it's
gonna be so cool guess what we're doing
we're having a robot party for him he
loves robots what's what is a robot
party well Kristen has gone to town
making robot stuff with her she got up
she bought a thing this thing this like
I don't even know what it does you put
special paper in it and it cuts out
paper and it and it makes stuff for you
like almost like a 3D printer like she's
printing out like different like letters
that look like computer letters and then
robots and eyeballs and [__] the thing
costs like four hundred dollars that's
it it sounds like it should cost more
than that
well I don't know it costs 400 oh okay
cost us some 400 because between three
and four hundred dollars okay you all
right use tongues like all messed up
yeah but um so she does that she's been
just having she loves to zone out and
just do that stuff it's really beautiful
I like that I wish I had something like
that but I don't I mean when you say
something like that what do you mean
something that you can just Zone I guess
working out can be like that for me but
like something where you could just zone
out she could Zone up for hours dude
I'll be texting I'm like is everything
okay and then she'll be like oh I'm so
sorry I'll get home and she's like I'm
so sorry I made this and it's like a
little like strawberry or something like
with like like a cardboard strawberry
I'm like that's what took you a few
hours
she doesn't stop motion [__] what do you
mean oh actual stop-motion animation
yeah okay you know that and so I didn't
know she still did that well no but I'm
just saying she has but that's her
personality she likes to she likes to
you know get involved with something
like that yeah you know he's like oh is
it okay I took my hat off yeah but
you're just doing a lot it hasn't even
been 10 minutes and you have nine
different looks you're like Robert De
Niro over the course of his career long
hair short hair hat mustache buff fat
it's too
hot
okay the temp is too damn high but then
you put it all on you got Casita it
doesn't matter I'm doing it on it's off
now it's better now I know I feel
insecure about my clean hair no it's
good dude your hair looks better this
way
I don't think so but my week was good
it's not about how it looks it's about
how it feels okay fine it may feel worse
it looks better that's what I'm saying
you're saying you don't think so I look
is yeah maybe I don't know but you're
get you're letting your feelings
yeah you know Cloud up how it looks yeah
maybe I guess but people look better
when they feel better don't they and
you're saying you know feel better
exactly because that's the thing because
do you think that because I was thinking
about this do you think that women like
men who are fit
is that it yeah uh what kind of fit like
you mean not outer space some women
I actually know just anecdotally women
who do like that and women who actually
are grossed out by muscles so
so
do you think how what percent do you
think okay let's let's back up here what
percent do you think it matters for a
guy if he's going to date a woman a
man's gonna date a woman what percent
matters body
to the heterosexual for the man talking
about men for the man no for the man for
the man term of the woman yeah
generally like average guy
uh
in terms of attraction or just like
just attraction I mean a lot almost 100
if it's just purely attraction yeah
but so what about for the female
again just for the attraction probably a
lot but less than that less than it is
for a man because men are extremely
Visual and women are much more like
feeling I think it's 80 for man okay and
20 for women
one t yeah I don't think it matters I
don't think it matters and that's coming
from a guy who's boy you're talking
about just Fitness yeah fit I'm talking
about a guy who like take the same body
on a woman translate that to a man use
that but see that's where I think it
doesn't even work so because because to
to men it's tip there's more of a
typical ideal woman which are my
heterosexual people obviously yeah to
women I don't think there is a more
typical like ideal man
taste is so varied for women I think
yeah when it comes in terms of
Attraction level physically yeah yeah
but my point is Fitness
on a fitness level on a on a right on a
I think it matters very little for women
and me too and that's coming from a guy
who's beat out I don't think you're that
Vietnam
what doesn't that mean you go like that
yeah yeah no you don't do that
what normal body you go like that or
like that you know no no you're like
this like that that's crazy dude you're
like the top of a why
yeah beat out but like a lazy y that
looks more like a u
so if you're a robot you're like a you
that's horrible and that's nothing like
a lot dude on Vita I look like a martini
glass no no no oh my God that's crazy
dude my shoulders go on for days my hips
are fine but then you look
like my let's really make the make the
whole picture all right man I don't know
oh you're saying I'm not like this
look at martini glass no you're not like
that you're like this
that's just two lines no no it's a
little bit like further out at the top
no that's stupid dude my lats are crazy
nope all right so dude I'm saying it's
coming from a guy who's physically fit
who looks great you know my shit's all
lumpy in the right ways and somebody I'm
saying it doesn't matter yeah I kind of
agree obviously it matters to some women
though to some women what amount of
women care those women are women that
use too much makeup you know what I mean
like no I think they do contouring they
look like a Kabuki theater person so
you're saying Kabuki theater makeup
women like guys who are
you know I mean I'm fit but guys who are
do you know what I mean Jack like Yogi
Doodle Dandy yeah but not like veed out
but like also veed out but also Yoki
Doodle Dandy I don't really know what
your point is it's so amorphous you're
not making a specific point you're just
like kind of all over the place I'm
saying that it doesn't matter if you're
fit for a guy but I am fit
it does matter though if you're unfit
that's what I'm saying it doesn't matter
if you're unfair but that's what we're
saying what I'm saying is it doesn't
matter if you're fit to attract women
yeah but I'm also very fair oh that's
the only point this is about you oh my
God no wonder I didn't understand and
for women and for men if they think oh
women oh I want a fit woman that's the
boom that's 90 percent
and for a man is to want and for a woman
is 20. you know why when I was little I
decided I didn't want to be like a
person who was always at the gym why
because you started to go to the gym all
the time at the end of high school and
you were constantly looking at yourself
in the mirror and I decided wow I don't
want to be the kind of person that's
always looking at myself in the mirror
like my brother does and so I decided
I'm never gonna be like that what's
happening it's a deeper no way dude yes
it was a good decision no deeper you
just didn't want to be like me when it's
healthy to be like me remember when John
Charles saw how I saw a buffet and he
said you ever put water down your chest
and go like this and just watch it
dribble down yeah yeah and I do you do
that no no I did it after he said it I
did it I was like is this even the thing
and I go and I go it's kind of tight all
right so let's go into the [__] show
we had a good time here so far riporn
the Super Bowl today oh nice okay this
comes out so okay
but we don't know the score we'll have
bad views but it's okay because you know
we'll have good views on Monday right
yep we don't know the score we wonder
what it's going to be it's going to be
maybe who knows I don't even know what
teams are in the Super Bowl it's gonna
be the chiefies versus the 90s okay the
90s no the Eagles the Eagles the Eagles
yeah yeah it'll be the Eagles okay all
right cool all right so let's let's go
did she freezing the iggies
hey Matt hey Chris so my younger brother
is refusing to come rock climbing with
me I'm a huge fan of rock climbing I've
been doing it many years and I coached
it for many years and I think my brother
would enjoy rock climbing for very
specific reasons that I've tried to
explain to him but when I invite him he
just says I don't want to and if I ask
him why he says I don't know I just
don't want to now I understand pressing
him is not a good healthy thing to do
and I know your stance on
um being pressured into doing something
you don't want to do by friends and
family but at the same time I'm sure you
guys have tried things out with friends
and family before that you didn't think
you'd enjoy and then you found out you
actually would enjoy it and it seems to
me that if you don't have a specific
reason for not wanting to do something
it's healthy to go try that thing see if
you like it and if you don't you just
don't so if my brother tried this one
time and he doesn't like it I would just
drop it forever and I think it's fair to
ask him to try it one time just for his
own sake to see if he actually enjoys it
because if he does we could do it
together and it would be an amazing
thing to do together but if he doesn't
he just doesn't
um am I being a dick here or is there
something to be said for trying
something out when you really have no
specific reason for not not wanting to
you just don't want to so you don't know
what's going on dick
you are Ben Shapiro
um but you're being selfish you're
talking about it would be good for him
it would be good for him but be good for
you no no this is what I I if he went
rock high would be good for you if you
went rock climbing once and then loved
it it would be good for you no it might
be good for him to open up to certain
activities I get that but here's the
deal you're coming at it from a lie you
have to say hey do this for me I want
you to do this because I'm going to
enjoy this yes and I would appreciate as
your brother this gift if you didn't cut
me off you would have known that's what
I was going to say too because he's the
one that wants it and it would be good
for him yeah he should come at it from a
will you do this for me now I know
you'll love it I know you'll love it I
know that makes me want to say no me too
yeah if you were to say I think he just
died if you were to say hey I really
want you to come do this for me I would
do it yes if you were to say you should
do this because you're gonna have a good
time I would say no it's like trying to
tell it's like trying to tell someone
you know them better than they know
themselves that's not a good strategy
also here's another thing too you
actually don't have to try something to
know if you like it or not definitely
not I don't like this notion what people
say hey how are you gonna know if you
don't try gay sex
there you go the buck stops there but no
one would say that about that the reason
you know you I know I don't want to get
all but the reason I know I wouldn't
like say skydiving
is because that looks terrifying and
guess what it is to people that don't
find it appealing exhilarating so no one
can sit there and tell me oh you'll love
skydiving Matt when I know I won't and
guess what I'm not gonna go with you no
matter how many times you ask so
skydiving and gay sex no there are more
things than that I know top things like
actual deep desire and preference that
doesn't count what we're talking about
skydiving and rock climbing aren't in
the same category what about when gay
guys come up to you and says hey gonna
know if you never tried it
then then you either you say the thing
about the deep inside no you say
whatever you want no I don't want to
though yeah that's it there you go so no
you can't make me well no one's trying
to make you right and I'm secure and if
they are then there's a real problem and
I and it's fine if you're gay but it's
just not my thing
great we're too far down the rabbit hole
about the gay thing at this point and
they might do it once it still could
mean you're not gay you just tried it
but I didn't do that did it and so
yeah I I agree though that the whole
here's here's you can have sex with so
many men and not be gay as long as in
your mind you're not gay here's I have
never done it here here's but that is
true the kind of person who says you
don't know if you like it unless you try
it maybe you just think you don't
deserve it kind of person
who wants you to do the thing
you're talking about what
what you said what what I said the words
I said I know what the first part is the
part I didn't hear no you aren't
listening is it more because I said
something and I I shouldn't have said
something I shouldn't have you're right
but what was the first part of what you
said the kind of person you can't say
what to what by the way which is what
you did I was highlighting how dumb it
was that you didn't know what I said
there's no excuse that was dumb so
that's why I didn't wow so go ahead the
kind of person that says
the thing that you're talking about
which is you don't know if you like
something unless you tried it is the
kind of person that wants you to do what
they want you to do is trying to just
use this employee strategy to get you to
do it yeah I agree they don't care about
you they want you to do it that's right
that's like my friend David Sullivan uh
steeper and I'm not gonna do it he made
me do pickleball and you know what I did
pick a ball and I had a good time but I
still didn't want to do it do you
understand that I still didn't like it
you had a good time and you didn't like
it yeah but that's not I don't want to
go again that's the thing that's
different than that I know but it's a
very nuanced thing because he's like
come on let's do pickleball and I was
there and I did talk about this on my
show congratulations you can go check it
out but I did do pickleball and I had a
good time and the only reason why I did
it was because next to the coffee shop
we got by happenstance and then we went
over we played pickleball and I liked it
I had a good time but that's it and I
don't really want to go again yeah okay
so so did I really like it yeah so you
can like something do it once and then
that's it of course I know but that's
weird though if you really like
something you'd want to do it again not
necessarily I know but also how much you
really like something if you only did it
once and then you're good not that much
but you liked it well enough
so did I really like it or did it not
like there's a scale you liked it like
well no yeah you didn't dislike it you
had a good time you're like an open
person it was enjoyable but you don't
want to go do it again but I'm pissed
off I had a good time doing it well
that's your job to talk about with your
therapist I'm a curmudgeon I guess
that's what it is right that's not what
that is but you are a conversion okay
hey we want to talk about DraftKings
listen NBA fans it's time to bring the
Hoops action to the palm of your hand
with DraftKings Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the NBA this
week new customers can bet five dollars
and win you're probably like well a few
bucks no they win 200 in free bets
instantly Plus for a limited time all
new and existing customers can get a no
sweat same game parlay every day go to
the DraftKings Sportsbook app today
opt-in and place the same game parlay on
any NBA game and if it doesn't hit
you'll get a free BET back there you go
I gotta go on this this this you're a
sports guy I am a sports guy yeah uh and
this Sunday I got my I know it's the
underdog but they're still
pretty good and they're going to beat
the Celtics the Grizzlies are going to
be the Celtics that's game today I got
my money on the Griz boss some good odds
there Grizzlies yeah griswas the grisp
boys Chris boys okay cool uh download
the app now and sign up with code
Lifeline new customers can bet five
dollars on the NBA and get 200 in free
bets instantly only at DraftKings
Sportsbook and official sports betting
partner of the NBA with code Lifeline
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply go Grizz boys
hey Matt and Chris my name is Jamie I'm
from Calgary Alberta I'm a huge [__]
fan of both of you guys but I want to
keep this as short as possible so here
it goes I like your stuff long story
short I was with a guy for about a year
and a half we were living together
we had a big blowout we broke up I gave
him two weeks to get out
he decided to move to his mom's house on
the east coast of Canada so he left most
of his
her hair part is your hair part
it's coming from right above her ear
okay well we're obviously meant to be
together okay continue stuff here for me
to mail him once he got out there Jesus
which is totally fine I guess one of the
things he did decide to take with him at
the time though was his PlayStation 5.
he loves video games I get it I'm not
knocking that all right you should but
he left his father's ashes here and he
has since asked me to do things like
take his father's ashes out of where I
have them stored now and like display
them on my mantle for his dad's birthday
um I have never met his dad in real life
he died before I got a chance to meet
him and they didn't even have a good
relationship
when he was alive
so I don't feel like I'm being
ridiculous in saying no to that
especially because he took his
PlayStation overtaking yeah
um I offered to mail them to him if it
was super important to him uh but he
didn't really want to do that say
anything to that so I assumed that was a
no
um I was saying that I'm a huge [__]
and I'm being unreasonable for not
taking his father's ashes out on his
birthday uh I just kind of want your
guys opinion because
I don't think that's unreasonable some
people do some people that he thinks
they're crazy I just want to know what
you guys what person is like thanks nah
he's right you are a [__] yeah that's
absurd you here's how here's how wrong
he is and then how right you are okay he
is
zero percent
right and so therefore 100 wrong and the
woman who submitted the video is a
hundred percent right and zero percent
wrong yeah okay that's it here's what
she has too much of a heart and a
conscience clearly this is what this is
how it goes you say hey can you put my
dad's ashes on it's his birthday can you
put my dad's ashes on your mental it's
his birthday oh actually I'm way ahead
he already did it oh
thanks yeah
why are you lying though just say no
it's an absurd thing to ask this guy's
crazy I know so you deal with crazy
people by giving them a logical
explanation you got a lot of crazy
here's what you say to me say to me hey
um it's my dad's birthday can you put
him on the mantle please no
you [__] [__] dude here's the deal
you oh first of all he's dead it's fine
he doesn't need to be higher up on his
birthday also he doesn't even care well
he's the guy doesn't care the guy
doesn't care he's just honestly he's
just trying to still have control over
them yeah that's totally what it is he's
trying to extend power and control over
you put even more of a reason to say no
put him on a mantle really okay I did it
yeah what were you wearing when you did
it you dude you can't
who are your friends also that said it's
okay you I is she making that up no I
don't think so you can't you the guy
took his PlayStation dude and not his
dad
[Music]
leave the dad take the PlayStation it's
like the leave the gun take the canola
yeah The Godfather wow
dude the dead father the worst guy
the dead father dude okay listen the
worst hey dude
I'm sure he took other things too so he
took the PlayStation and like socks yeah
but not his dad yeah he left his dad and
his ex-girlfriend's house but he took
socks and then duh don't mail him
also
mail my dad is
also why don't mail them like what do
you think
we're gonna get into no it's not a
valuable thing like nobody's gonna steal
your dad
is that why that's not even why though I
think it's going to get like messed up a
Transit but like the truth is the only
time things get messed up in charge of
somebody steals your package and let me
tell you something nobody's gonna steal
your dad oh some people don't have that
nobody's just selling dad's ashes okay I
always wanted to die I always wanted Dad
what
if it got lost it could get lost you
lost it honestly he should live the rest
of his life in shame for taking his
[__] PlayStation instead of his dad
yeah honestly if if they mail ball the
PlayStation is Dad and he would be more
mad that they lost the PlayStation
according to how he's been absolutely
and now here's here's the real thing
though tell your ex-boyfriend to tune in
send him the clip exactly at this
endpoint and this message is for you
you're a bad son okay next video uh and
and also uh
go get your dad
also go back in time and don't leave
your dad okay yeah you know also
throw him in the ocean also you don't
care about your dad you left him at your
ex-girlfriend's house and he took the
PlayStation five I don't really get when
someone dies and you get their ashes and
[__] and just no I totally get the
people they're so cinnamon I wouldn't do
it but I totally get it saying I
wouldn't do it yeah I would just have
when like when our parents died I just
want to have them and prop them up yeah
fill them I want to put them in like
taxidermize them yeah but put them in my
kitchen like not even like in a far away
weird room you can have Dad I want to
sit mom at the uh dining my dining table
oh really yeah half into a meal or what
no so I have always I'm eating a meal
with her I got you no matter what I want
Dad to be uh up and propped up making
pasta
or no just fixing the garbage disposal
because he's always doing that more than
dude our dad this is how you know my dad
our dad yeah yeah broke the garbage
disposal you hear from the kitchen
you're in another room you hear God damn
it yes exactly yes dude and we go oh we
broke it dude he puts everything garbage
disposal is supposed to be supposed to
be for crumbs by the way like not yeah
my dad will be like uh we're not using
this wicker chair anymore
yeah it's not a wood chipper that's
unbelievable dude and then he's like
he's like God damn it it's also not even
just crumbs it's like you can put bigger
pieces of food in there but only food
yeah but also you're not supposed to put
like full sandwiches down there and
stuff you're not correct but is that
what he's doing no yeah he's putting it
he puts everything down there dude
wow he puts everything down there still
you know he's literally broken his girl
we're supposed eight times at least so
many times at least eight times uh but
but no but so he yeah he I don't know if
he does it anymore but I bet he does he
got him and a more hardcore industrial
strength garbage I bet he still does
yeah he still puts like rolling pins
down there you know yeah yeah all right
anyway
next
what's up guys
just wanted to hear your thoughts real
quick on PDA uh for some reason I
noticed couples doing it a lot
um and it's not just a quick you know
one second Peck
obsession with tongue lip biting don't
get me wrong of course there's a time
and place for it but when you're on
public uh you know crowded
Transportation you can't really Escape
it it just makes me feel uncomfortable
especially if I'm in a relationship I
wouldn't want to do that in front of a
ton of strangers
[Laughter]
and it's all good and I you know it
doesn't really matter but I just think
it's kind of would you say that somebody
who's doing that is a sled and not worth
my time I've and I made the right
decision I've evolved on my feelings
about this it used to gross me out and
make me think like what is wrong with
those people now I'm kind of just like
amazed at people who do it and I just
like if you're gonna do that in public
I'm gonna just stare at you like this is
the price you pay and if you even for
one second go what are you looking at
I'm gonna say you yeah because you guys
are hooking up in front because you're
[__] right there so what do you think
you guys are [__] in front of me I'm
looking at you so what do you think is
the line like obviously two people can
hold hands that's nice that's not even
that arm around okay holding
resting and then there's kissing you
think that's the line I think tit
sucking is the line sucking on tits wow
yeah that's way too so kissing is not
too far what about making out like hard
making out like french kissing well now
I'm saying that yeah because I was
saying kissing and then I said what
about making out and then you said hard
fresh core kissing yeah sure is that
what you mean like like making our
friends oh I'm French so I just want to
make sure we're talking about okay well
part of me sure
but yes making out as in French kissing
hardcore okay so that I think that's
that's like a little weird but it's not
like you don't think it's too much
upsetting okay or anything okay now let
me let me put it to you like this okay
yeah same sex
okay it's the same line no but okay for
you but it's a little weird sometimes
people think well yeah but when there's
two of the same sex people doing it well
those people are sucking it so you even
gave them an accident for a reason
that's all I'm gonna leave it at that
okay yeah well they're not there
right okay yeah they're all for
Birmingham Alabama so um so yeah so no
yeah but my point is same for same-sex
and also it's all the same all the same
okay hardcore making out is like a
little weird but it's not I agree same
if you're like at a stadium like at a
sporting event that would be a little
bit weird but if you're like a Park
which is I'm assuming where most people
are doing these kinds of things like
away from other people
a little less weird it has to do with
proximity to other people if they're in
public but not like right on top of you
yeah or others okay it's not that weird
so if you're a block away in a park yeah
and people can't really see you but
maybe you can kind of see them from your
apartment you're gonna have like she's
just he's fully inside her and she's
riding I mean I've seen that oh really
and I'm just like where posted up behind
a tree and I'm gonna go yeah
um because
also I've seen I mean I've seen so much
of that like in other people's windows
oh really yeah so the first day I moved
into my place in New York yeah I was
moving in moving my stuff in putting my
AC unit in my window and directly across
2nd Avenue I saw
um a woman and a man having sex from
behind it was as if they were on display
for me whoa and and uh the guy was the
guy was [__] her from behind with his
penis and she was in front bent over
with her kind of facing and he was
sticking his penis into reverse I know
how it goes so uh did you get turned on
no I was just like oh my God and I got
my Coleman and did he get turned on and
then we had sex uh I at one time was
watching some a woman have sex with a
man and I couldn't believe it uh and it
was at my place and then I realized it
was me
it felt so good I was like what the what
the hell is going on yeah that is weird
and then I was like oh God it's me
cold cold
ah
oh yeah well anyway blind with
sunglasses
okay next one wow
oh
hey Chris and Matt my name is Joe I'm
from Charlotte North Carolina and I have
a question for you guys so
me and my wife we've been married since
2017 been together since 2012. since we
got married we have had two children a
four-year-old and two-year-old both boys
um
and obviously with that pregnancy came
some weight gain which I don't have a
problem with I know it might sound like
I do but
um I actually find it very attractive
cool however since gaining that weight
my wife has snored uncontrollably I mean
sometimes it sounds like she stops
breathing and I'm just worried about the
health concerns over anything I'm still
attracted to her I still love her
beautiful but she doesn't understand
that that weight is really putting her
in a position to not live a long life
and I need a way to bring that up to her
um I know it's very sensitive subject
um but any help would be greatly
appreciated thank you guys
I mean damn say that freaky situation
yeah I guess so usually I will say that
usually people who call in or or send a
video in to this show say how should I
approach a subject and I think like 80
of the time they should just approach it
how they approached it to us I mean
that's such a sticky situation because
way because of the obvious thing yeah
honestly even for men for a woman way
different yeah but here's here's
honestly what I think I think
if we're talking about because obviously
obesity
is very often if not always
a health risk
so I think maybe compare it like lead
into it
the way he just said it was good but if
you wanted to like soften the landing
even more you want I might want to talk
about like look like maybe there was a
point where one of you smoked and the
other one asked you to stop smoking
maybe there was a point one of you drank
too much I asked you to stop drinking
bring that up
as the context as like the groundwork
for what you're going to bring up with
the weight thing because what you want
to make clear you're not doing is saying
honey you way too much and I don't like
it or something along those lines well
it's the opposite he said he does like
it exactly so even more of a reason why
you don't want to make it sound like
that you want to make clear that it up
front that it's a health thing unlike
you just did with us he brought up the
health thing late and you want to bring
that up first thing first first good
advice you want to make it a house
because it is because that's what it is
it is if what you're saying is honest
and we have no reason not to believe you
it's it's a health concern and just like
if she were smoking or you were smoking
and she wanted to bring it up with you
or or drinking too much or doing drugs
or or anything unhealthy
um
even just like eating too much sugar
whatever like you want your partner to
live as long as possible not only live
as long as possible but live healthy and
happy for as long as possible and if
someone is
not aware of how much damage they're
doing to themselves it actually as
uncomfortable as it may be it is
your partner's responsibility or in your
case your responsibility to your partner
to say something have you ever seen fit
to Fat to fit
did you just stutter a lot nope that's
actually what the show is called fit to
Fat to fit no so it starts out with
somebody who's fit and they know someone
who's fat and they fit person gets fat
they spend four months getting as fat as
the person and then lose it with them
and they both lose it oh you could do
fit to Fat to fit
okay you could be like look sweet
doesn't that sound really unhealthy
though it is but it's not good to gain
weight really fast or lose weight but
you will if she loses weight then it is
eventually will uh ultimately will just
be healthy for her I don't think you
should do that but here's the thing yeah
I don't before you bring it up ramp up
how much is you're like wow baby you
look great whoa and also sorry but maybe
like have sex a few times yeah and make
it clear that you enjoyed it and are
enjoying it while you're doing it yeah
yeah yeah yeah or bring it up during sex
oh yeah oh you know you snore yeah yeah
yeah yeah you snore yeah I think maybe
you lose a little bit of weight
because it's a healthy
there's proof called
wow
um
and there's some proof baby you want
some proof what's the proof
our car a car
yeah dude I I hear you though dude I get
it man
um what just that
uh
um
we give great advisors why are things
funnier when you've just taken a sip of
something because you shouldn't be
laughing oh so naughty we're not
everybody likes to live naughty we are
naughty intrinsically my teacher says
not to be naughty but we're nodding we
are Naughty by Nature it's true not a
nature all right what's his name was
right what's his name Treach he was so
right yeah he was a good actor though
church was a good actor but he didn't
get the part that Tupac got on juice
because Tupac was a better actor what do
you mean they auditioned for Seattle oh
I didn't know that tretch went in to do
the audition for juice and then
Tupac went into the artificial I
actually don't know who went first but
tretch speaks of it as oh I'm not gonna
get this part because you heard him
through the wall oh they were in the
same room yeah wow yeah Tupac's an
amazing actor but Jeff was good too yeah
yeah why do you say that though well I
say what that church was a good actor
because we just brought him up and I
don't know but I don't know but what did
you see him in oh I don't even remember
it wasn't he in uh Higher Learning
was he I think he was Busta Rhymes was I
don't know
Omar episode in Higher Learning I mean a
lot of people are in Higher Learning
dude how long has Michael Rappaport been
around 75 and he's only like 50. you
know what he makes him laugh so hard in
small time Crooks oh dude he is so funny
in that movie I know he's so funny he
really is so funny
um Anthony Chris is his name wow
let's go ahead he still is dude yeah he
that guy is a handsome dude
he's in a movie that is so funny he's
got nothing to lose oh wow oh no it's a
soundtrack all right he's in Juice yeah
but he didn't get the part that that
people I see uh there is such a funny
look up actor only yeah dude there's a
there was a movie that he's in that is
so funny
and I put uh
it's a while it was a while ago yeah uh
it is the uh no no no no players ball no
he's in The Sopranos oh wow as trash wow
oh he is in The Sopranos he is yeah I
don't know what the movie is but
he's in some movie where he is
wow look how many things oh it's loving
a bullet is loving a bullet loving a
bullet
oh he's in Soul Food
it's look at that it's like this movie
this guy this movie
there's a scene in this movie where
somebody shoots at him and he he goes
down on one hand dude like this kicks
his feet up and the bullet goes under
him it's like me with the ear last
episode with the ear yeah you're trying
to get like you you get you get shot at
and then you pull out your gauged ear
yeah don't remember that I do remember
that one but it's not like that no it's
just like that because he used his whole
body to do it was um it's not even even
plyometric people will be like what the
[__] is he doing well anyway it was so
he avoided the bullet right I put it on
Instagram and Chris Rock liked it
who
were we giving advice to just now Trench
no really the guy the guy who with the
with the wife that he said he wanted oh
yeah make it a health thing yeah be
really bleed with the whole thing and be
real care
feel okay cool all right care Rodney
Dangerfield
hey guys bundled it's Bruce again so
who's this guy again creatively he
wanted to quit his job oh yeah oh his
uncle or something was that the guy who
who worked for his father-in-law
but I don't remember that so this guy
has 20 layers on yeah right he wanted to
quit and pursue a different thing
altogether because he was working with
his father-in-law and now he's he's his
job is not wearing too many clothes his
job now is to be always confusing okay
you said how do I quit okay okay
go ahead quitting your job over a
podcast
probably not my best date yet all right
now I remember but you fired me so I
guess oh same outcome whatever because
of the podcast
and
Booyah about to kill himself and uh on a
building
yeah you guys hiring
wow that was a good submission
and then literally took ricin after this
and shook so hard on the concrete
dude he honestly uh he got fired I
wonder if he did get fired because of
the pumpkin I think the implication was
he got fired because of this no I don't
think that's the implication but I
wonder if it didn't want to ask as well
because it's salacious well I think he
did get fired because of us we're
naughty I think that he is
um
yeah we're not hiring we've got our
Force we've got our crew no job for you
so we can hang our clothes up on him
because he clearly likes that yeah I do
have some extra clothes that you might
want
um but that's uh we're sorry to hear
about you being fired but also maybe he
wanted to get when a door closes another
one opens right but he literally wanted
to get fire if I remember correctly he
wanted to get fired but he was like I
hope my boss sees this wasn't he I
remember that no I don't think so but
what I'm saying is true but I wanted to
be true what I said so it is true that's
fine but I'm saying there's another door
somewhere find that and walk through it
and it's not this it's you're not
working it's not you're really mean to
us you're really stretching that cliche
so what I'm saying is that's good for
you thank you thank you when something
bad happens to you yeah you've got to do
something to flip it on its ass and you
go thank your life thank you very much
this is a learning experience I'm gonna
grow from this so thank you I mean I
agree with that but you know your boss
do that I don't do that okay yeah that's
good advice but you don't do that yeah
well no I'm I'm uh I don't do that
either it's too hard if you can do that
though it's it's good I do do that
sometimes but then sometimes I get in
certain moves and moods and I go oh man
I'm not doing that but I try to I always
try to make things the best thing that
ever happened to me oh wow it's also
deeper yeah it sounds like it okay now
you see that so defensivo is what it is
all right next next
hey Chris and Matt I'm Nina my boyfriend
and I love the Pod we're true babies
Chris we recently got tickets to see you
in Tulsa can't wait so I'm gonna jump
right into it my boyfriend and I have
been living together for two years
dating since I was a freshman in college
but here's the thing he's seven years
older than me so by the time we started
dating he was already out of college
there's this part of me that you know
despite the perfect relationship we have
and and the fact that we see a future
together I feel like I'm missing out on
experiences at College I wanna like Live
It Up
um there's a big part of me that's kind
of addicted to the chase of new
relationships and new guys and
um you know I kind of want to like have
the ability to flirt with other guys and
live it up while I'm young so what do
you say should he let me have a hoe
phase or should I just hunker down and
make the future my priority and just
accept that I've met the one any advice
is appreciated thanks guys what an
awesome attitude about this should he
let me have a whole face I mean just
knowing calling it like like a Spate of
space you should if you actually really
think
uh
uh I guess it's there's a few things
going on here if you really think that
that's something you want before you
truly settle down you should bring it up
but what is gonna have to happen is
you're gonna have to let him do the same
thing too because it can't just be you
who's like free and he's just waiting
for you to finish uh and that obviously
would work if this was a guy calling in
about him and his girlfriend it's the
same thing yeah you can't have a
partnership if it's not fair if you're
getting some cut he's gonna get some cut
okay
um don't say that but
um
also though I will say I know a couple
specifically that were together for a
really long time they were about to get
married and the woman said
I love you very much I really want to
get married and I'm really looking
forward to it and I can't wait to spend
the rest of my life with you but we've
been together so long and since we were
so young I want between now and now
between now and our wedding just that
period to be able to see other people
put some stuff in my face but to be able
to see other people but to put some
stuff so she starts going on dates with
a few different guys and like actually
doing it but always coming up in her
face Oops stop I'm not interrupting I'm
coloring it no you are interrupting no
you interrupted yourself
stop okay but just can you say and so
she would go on dates with these guys
and then oops and then she would come
home to him at night every night she
would never like
not tell him what was going on it was a
very honest thing he never wanted to do
it in the first place though he finally
does it once with a girl so he ends up
really liking though because that's the
kind of guy he is he's very like one
person-centric right but he ends up
going like too far with her and really
liking her and she really likes him and
then one like night he came home like
later than he had said he was going to
come home and she finally broke and
specifically asked like why are you late
what's going on whatever and he told her
and she flipped out yeah and almost
tanked the entire relationship because
she was so jealous of what the guy was
doing with this other woman so what I'm
that's the long version of saying be
careful right be careful what you got is
something great right don't think it
grows on trees because if you mess this
thing up it might not be fixable and
here's the thing dude
everyone's gonna think you're talking
about me
you're not
I don't even know what you mean and I
know who you're talking about too
what are you saying it's not me
people are gonna be like you're talking
about your brother oh no it's not you no
hey dude and I know but I know who it is
okay stop doing that
you don't even have a clue what is you
don't even know what they are no I
thought it was uh
no you some other you don't know these
people okay so shut your mouth that's
fine but so shut your mouth and we're
good but but what uh my point is to get
it out there it wasn't me it was
somebody that I thought Shaggy
that you that you know that I don't know
okay fine but what I'm saying is uh
this is something that look I don't
for people who are normal people that
don't have a problem with you know uh
love don't have a problem with sex don't
have a problem with sleeping around
don't have a problem flirting is fine
like you can flirt you're not going to
do anything if you're not going to do
anything if if the guy is secure enough
he should be he's out of college and
[__] he should be like oh it's fine you
can flirt with whoever you want I don't
care yeah but she's obviously talking
about a little bit more I know she is
but she may not know what she wants she
may think that that's what she wants and
then do it and look The Grass Is Always
Greener but the point is flirting is
probably enough I'm guessing you seem
like a sound person and you found
somebody that you might be with for the
rest of your life it I would say
you know I get it I get it because
especially because he's not with you in
college it's a little different you
don't feel like you're living that
college lifestyle you're not living
living up your youth but if you got a
good thing if you really think he's the
one genuinely like not because that's
what's supposed to happen if you really
think that this dude is the one you want
to be the rest with the rest of your
life then I don't think you should do it
but if you if you have any sort of you
know doubt any sort of Doubt then I
think that you should do it I think that
you should say look I need to go through
my whole face but not don't put it like
that but I want to put some stuff on my
face I just think I mean maybe you have
already but if you haven't certainly I
think you should talk to him about it
yeah and just again be careful but like
you know be delicate because feelings
are intense about this kind of stuff
yeah explosive sometimes but like
it's clearly enough on your mind that
you called in to us uh you might want to
bring it up with him as you said he's
probably much more mature than most guys
your age so it might not be actually
that much of a bomb to drop on him
um and who knows maybe he'll be like oh
yeah it's a great idea I think you
should do that and I'm gonna go do it
too and then but still and then we're
gonna ruin our lives that way right you
know yeah but again it's a decision you
guys make together and that's better
here's the other thing too you seem like
the kind of person where you're like hey
I want to go out and do my thing and
you're just gonna go out and meet
another guy and then be with him
like you're saying you don't think I
don't think she has it in there to
really be a hoe
how how what energy because I read
people and I'm I'm not saying I'm like
Sherlock Holmes but like I I feel a
certain way about certain people and
just hearing what she's talking and how
she's talking about it I don't really
think she has it in her to be a hoe
I don't think she does
I think that she's the kind of person
that would just like be like uh you know
sleep with one or two guys
and that's a whole face to her face to
her and then uh she met the guy and now
she's like she likes this guy and the
other guy's asked out I don't know I
don't so you don't even think she likes
this guy that much I don't I don't think
this guy's the one
I don't think this guy's the one
I think he is okay yeah
okay I or rather I think she thinks he
is yeah yeah okay I think she knows deep
down that he might not be the one oh
okay well now you're psychoanalyzing but
okay that's just what I think okay all
right one more one more I'm gonna just
say this about the next one yeah um it's
a follow-up okay and I didn't come from
the same woman she's like I just I just
I just had sex with a bunch of guys I
mean currently in my whole face I did it
um vet the video I didn't even watch it
I said I I walked by this and so Barbie
because you know what it's about no
because I know oh it's from yeah it's a
follower okay okay so this could be
boring you didn't even vet it okay all
right cool well that's fun let's see
mystery video
okay oh I sent in a video oh yeah
talking about the right way to drink
something right and no one seemed to
know what was going on in that yeah
and I'm gonna get straight to the point
what I was talking about is the
hard-hitting issues
um Chris yeah like you have an issue
about like
cheeseburger is a snack and that's
that's a hard topic and we need to be
talking about that and how if you eat a
cheeseburger and you're watching TV you
got both stimulations at the right time
yeah I get the right thing to do but if
you lay down you have too many
stimulations going at once right so
that's what I'm talking about with the
drink like
that is the right way to do something
and not nobody talks about that but it's
right and we need to be talking about
that more right rather than like I said
the weather and I get it um I can't
force it and I will force it in my
conversations oh wow I'm not having a
debate about it oh well then you saw I
I'm going to say this is the right way
to do something I'm like spreading
knowledge I'm not trying to have a
conversation
I'm telling you no you're doing this now
um
okay
peace no one really knew it was like you
should drink this way and not this way
and that's what I should tell people
when I meet them also all you just did
in this video is tell us how shitty you
are in every conversation when you meet
people I'm not gonna listen to them yeah
it's not gonna be a conversation this is
literally telling them what's best yeah
I mean imagine if I was like hey what's
up nice to meet you I'm Chris hey hey
man our Burger's a snack dude you should
eat two for lunch like
dude
you would be a lunatic yeah
like uh and then you go what no no no no
no no no that's it we're not talking
about it anymore it wasn't kind of a
meal no no no no you gotta meet someone
else hey Frank if you lay down and eat a
burger that's too much simulation nice
to meet you
I mean this guy is just
Gonna Get a Grip yeah and he also he
could be 17 but could be 37. yeah dude
the guy is Lil xan and it's all good
he's losing without the tattoos and it's
fine but also uh uh he's one of those
guys where you can't tell if he has
braces or not and then also yeah dude
yeah he is yep and then ALS he died he
did I ruined it and he also did let's
find the way it was and Michael ruined
it um and then also dude
um so [__] absolutely boring and if
he meets somebody like that gonna be I'm
gonna have a zero friends I think I have
zero yeah if you have any friends right
now you're gonna lose him [__]
friends we love the guy though and yeah
call in again yeah for real we love you
dude thank you for watching thank you
for calling in twice with two of the
most utter [__] videos I've ever
heard in my life give us a third one
yeah please give us our third one we
dare you to make sense this time and
explain to us also another thing besides
the drink thing that you feel that is a
hard-hitting issue because so far you
called them twice and you have only one
example that we don't even understand we
don't understand it so but uh so give us
another one there's got to be more
because the burger is a snack one is
very clear that's when I say one
Burger's a snack you're not gonna eat
one for lunch it's two for lunch that's
a meal fat
that's a fact absolutely obese all right
cool all right well we're done well
that's it look I've got to be in New
York at the Beacon Theater February 18th
Rhode Island February 17th I'm going to
be in uh Boise uh Salt Lake City I'm
gonna be in uh uh Tulsa Midland Texas
Austin Texas two shows Minneapolis two
shows Milwaukee uh Columbus Ohio
Cincinnati and all that so go to
chrisley.com to get your tickets
go to mattdelia.com for some one-on-one
Mano Amano sessions advice a little back
and forth give you what you need to get
through the week the month the year your
life mattelia.com uh book them there and
then if you have a question click the
link in the description below or go to
watch lifestyle.com and if you want
you're sick as hell Lifeline merch go to
lifelinemerch.com and also subscribe to
the channel we love it
um join super good and leave us a
comment man let us know uh let us know
how you're feeling about the show or
something like that it helps yogurt we
gotta boost it up you know what I mean
because they shot up in your boy and
bing bing bong baby baby
and we will force you next
the worst
[Music]